before when I was around 12 my oldest
brother decided that he thought it would
be funny if he farted in my mouth yeah
my sibling you understand that's funny
so
by the way and I remember I was fighting
right fight but it didn't matter he was
so much bigger than me I would get the
shipping out of me and
Park them up
and I remember going to my dad and
saying he's falling in my mouth
[Music]
and my dad was like what are you doing
he was like I was like I'm fighting you
I'm fighting him but he's just too
strong
and it beats me up and then he farts in
my mouth
my dad was like well
maybe you should stop fighting
I said what and he goes look you can
either get beat up and get a fart in the
mouth or just take the four in the mouth
and I was like or you can ask him to
stop doing that
which is the reason I came to you to
begin with not for life advice
I just want you to get this dude to stop
farting in my mouth that's all
and your advice to me is just take it
I will tell you though
I remember next time my brother was like
I'm gonna pour your mouth and I just
went
[Music]
so I thought my dad was a big dummy
turned out the exact right planes
[Music]
I like to smoke weed
[Applause]
[Music]